Welcome back everyone
Its Charlie, Marvel dropped another brand new teaser
for What If Season 3. The Showrunner
the writers have been talking about the new episodes,
the characters dropping more footage
and some metaphorically and big literal characters
coming back like the Eternals and the Celestials.
So we'll break it all down and I know a lot of people
ask you about the X-Men characters,
so they did explain what's happening with the X-Men.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
It does sound like they're going to try and release the
What If episodes
way sooner than we thought, but they haven't announced
an official release date yet.
The next Big Marvel thing will actually be the X-Men
97 episodes.
I'll be doing full episode videos for that.
That'll all release before Deadpool three comes out.
Deadpool three is like the only traditional MCU movie
that's coming out this year
they just happens to feature a lot
a lot of X-Men related stuff.
we're supposed to get that first official Deadpool
three trailer at the Super Bowl in a couple of weeks.
but just starting with the literal biggest stuff first,
they're finally doing more mutants,
starting with Namor.
They didn't say what his episode is going to be.
that's not where it is coming back, his name
or to do the voice of the character in his episodes.
usually when they bring the movie actors back
to play their characters, they're in a couple different
episodes name More is one of the few
canonical mutants in the MCU right now.
Next to Ms. Marvel, they're probably others.
The Kevin Feige just hasn't revealed yet.
Mostly waiting on Deadpool
three to do that version of Hugh Jackman's Wolverine.
Bring back
all the legacy Fox Marvel actors for X-Men stuff.
Fantastic Four actors, They'll have their own version
of Spider-Man No Way Home like X-Men.
No Way Home is a sort of big swansong
honoring all the old Fox X-Men movies.
Fantastic Four movies before they recast all the actors
and reboot it all inside the MCU, the
what If showrunners also said that's the main reason
why they haven't done any core X-Men episodes?
Because you think they would have gone wild
with all the X-Men powers.
Like it just plays for really, really cool episodes.
apparently they're under strict orders by Kevin Feige
to not use the core X-Men characters until they debut
in the new live action MCU X-Men movie
that they announced a while ago
that ones meant to be the big reboot
of most of the characters.
this is some of the X-Men
won't be featured during that first new one.
Like they're waiting longer
to introduce the new MCU Wolverine with the new actor
because Hugh Jackman has a contract
to stay through Avengers Secret wars.
Whenever that winds up happening.
and because all the delays with Avengers
five and Avengers six, all that stuff, it looks like
Kevin Feige might be releasing the new X-Men movie,
the new live action X-Men movie before Secret Wars.
Now, they've been having all kinds of problems
with Avengers five.
I've already done separate videos about that,
but it sounds like they might actually be turning
Avengers five into like Secret Wars
part one and just making
a multipart Secret Wars movie
and just using different titles.
they're supposed to be setting that
all up during Deadpool three.
So I'll talk more about that in my Deadpool
three videos.
But X-Men
97 episodes are meant to be set in another universe.
That's why they have no issue in doing multiple new
seasons of that before the new live action X-Men movie.
So there will be a lot of X-Men
related stuff happening in the next couple of years.
sounds like Namor is about as close as we're
getting to X-Men on whatever Season three at least.
But the next big characters coming back
are the Eternals and the Celestials.
Like literally big characters.
They're finally doing more with them.
there's so many hanging plot threads
that they set up in the Eternals movie announcements
about sequel movies, them paying off the Dead Celestial
and the Indian Ocean during Captain America four.
It's taken forever for them to address that stuff.
it as you would probably expect the
what if season three episodes probably will not address
that either, mostly because it's meant to be set
in a completely alternate timeline, alternate universe
where things go down differently.
That's the whole premise of the What if series.
Like what if things happened differently?
Drew Meg is the first eternal
that they've confirmed is coming back.
I don't think they're going to bring all the Eternals
back just because there were so many of them.
It would destroy the budget of the show if they
featured all them and scheduling would be a nightmare.
But. I think the episode will play
on the idea of the emergence, but it'll be set during
a different part of the timeline
because they won't have every single character back
like they'll be some other threat
that involves the emergence in the Celestials.
but it might just be set earlier in the timeline
like the same way we saw the 1980s Avengers
episodes during season two in the main
villain of season three is supposed to be
Iran, an evil member of the watchers Res and Juanita's
nephew.
He's actually a member of What's his Immediate Family.
We learned more about the Watchers race
just in general during season three as well.
we saw the watchers race
during Guardians of the Galaxy Volume two.
So like there are multiple watchers inside the MCU,
but during the would have series
Uatu is the only watcher they've ever featured
or referenced
for those of you that are like, wait a minute,
this raises all kinds of other questions, too.
Like, can watchers actually have children in?
The answer is yes, they do breed biologically.
Theirs is a highly advanced race
that lives on a higher dimension.
you could take the Marvel
comic book writers for that, like,
wait a minute, why would higher dimension
level beings breed like normal humans?
Wouldn't they have some more advanced way
of propagating their race?
nope.
Turns out they like to do it the old fashioned way.
Iran is a marvel comic book character.
He debuted in the original Captain
Marvel Comics back in 1975,
but he mostly messed with the Fantastic
Four characters appearing again later in their comics.
over to the main Watcher has always mostly been
a fantastic four base character, so that makes sense.
Like they mostly appear in Fantastic Four stories.
My assumption in the context of season three you watch
you will be forced to confront his own family, Iran
trying to stop him from meddling
in the affairs of the main dimension,
the same way that he tried to avoid meddling in affairs
during what if season
two, even though Supreme Strange was going crazy
during season two with the multiverse
doing a little mini version of Secret Wars
for those of you
that did not watch the season two finale,
this is kind of what Secret Wars is going to look like.
watch two fighting other watchers fighting Iran.
His nephew is also right out of the comics.
Do I don't know if we'll see another live action
version of a watch two during the new Fantastic
Four movie we've already seen live Action watchers,
like I said, during Guardians of the Galaxy two.
So they're already canonized to the MCU.
Jeffrey Wright
also did a brief blink and you'll miss a cameo
as live action uatu during the
I Am Groot season two episodes.
So technically
he has already appeared inside the MCU can.
Can he see me?
No. I'm a fifth dimensional being.
No, sorry.
He's just putting on a little show.
the brand new footage and scenes
that they released teasers for includes
Sam Wilson's Captain America in his current new suit.
He's going to get another new one
during Captain America four.
We actually just got a look at that.
It looks a little bit more like Steve Rogers,
who crossed with his new Falcon suit.
but this one.
And what if season three is just based on the white
one that he got during Falcon and the Winter Soldier?
He's with Monica Rambeau. That's Bucky behind them.
If you couldn't tell and notice behind them
there's a shield logo.
So whichever universe this particular episode
takes place in Shield still exists in present day.
notice that both Captain America
and Monica Rambeau have their own Gundam.
These Mechs are meant to be references
to Gundam Marvel's flirted briefly
with anime inspired crossovers in Avengers
stories told in the manga format.
Like stories are geared towards manga
audiences, Characters are drawn
and animated in similar styles,
but it's still a pretty rare thing.
It's just Marvel experimenting with doing anime
based on Marvel stuff.
this is just an example of things working in reverse,
which is usually how things go.
Like there are a lot of Western cartoons
that are inspired by anime.
Best example of that is Avatar The Last Airbender,
which technically is not anime.
It's like anime. Inspired.
But there's always a lot of confusion about that.
Like what's the difference between anime and things
that are anime inspired technically to be called anime?
It has to be produced inside Japan by Japanese studios.
probably one of the most famous
one of the biggest examples of anime inspiring
moments inside Marvel movies.
Inside the MCU is actually the Killmonger character.
Michael B Jordan is a long time
animate than in real life, particularly of Dragonball,
So notice the Killmonger suit was designed to look
just like Vegeta suit
because Killmonger is basically the vegeta of the MCU
And even though now in present day
it's a little awkward because of the circumstances
surrounding Jonathan Majors.
A while ago, when The Last Creed movie came out,
he talked about doing
all of his fight scenes based on theme as anime fights.
Break it down
without nerding out too much.
You seen so many fights throughout the Rocky and Creed
franchise, and I really want to put my spin on it.
You know how to make these fights different and,
you know.
Had you been able to go back to Naruto, to my hero
academia, all those different,
you know, anime that I've watched growing up?
There's inherent spirit to them and how they fight,
you know, and their bonds and their relationships
and all that good stuff.
But it's very similar to the Brotherhood
and bond that we have.
And his relationship to his family as well.
So I tried to key in on some of those key moments.
And yeah, they're in there.
They're there in a lot of the fight.
Is there one specific moment
you can give us to look out for from a specific anime?
I would say from the Dragon Ball universe.
Dragon was a universe.
There's a there's a punch.
Me and me in Damien's fight
where there's a dragon was a punch that's in there.
even though it's a little strange watching that
because of what happened with Jonathan Majors
the last couple of months,
there's still a solid list of anime there to check out.
If you haven't seen those original fights,
those are based on
They're couple other brand new scenes from season
three, too.
This is Bill Foster's Goliath holding tiny red guardian
in another shot of Bucky in Red Guardian.
I think those two scenes are probably
from the same episode, in
They might be from the Red Guardian Winter Soldier
Team Up episode that they released earlier this year.
it's jammed.
You know what Kamarck said about machines?
They make men lazy.
Stop. Stop.
It's over.
Surrender yourself.
I've already done a longer video
about all the Easter eggs during that.
But that episode is basically.
What if Red Guardian joined the Avengers earlier in the
timeline before Captain America came out of the ice?
So it's kind of like,
what if Red Guardian pulled the Black Widow in, broke
from the Russians in the red Room earlier
in the timeline, defecting to the United States?
there's a whole bunch of stuff coming up.
I'll try to do videos for everything
as quickly as possible.
We just got some more news about the Blade movie
with some cool connections to Kit
Harington's Black Knight character.
So I'll try to do a video for that next.
big reminder, a whole bunch of Deadpool
three stuff coming soon.
Click here for that brand new teaser
trailer and click here for that other longer.
What if Season three trailer?
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!